i am indeed brian kilmeade and for laura
ingram special edition of the ingram
angle comes your way right now a lot
going on
will she or won't she that is the
question as it relates to potential
thailand the taiwan trip by speaker
pelosi now at this hour all signs point
to the speaker making the visit it would
happen in just a matter of a few hours
or about 12 hours behind us
and if anything happens we'll tell you
right away now according to the ahead of
us i should say according to the wall
street journal it isn't a matter of
whether she goes to taiwan but rather
whether rather she spends the night in
taipei or not the chinese have issued
threats throughout the speaker's
deliberations as you probably know
saying yesterday that the military will
not sit idly by while she visits really
their media organs are going even
further promising military involvement
even suggesting they might even shoot a
plane down oh isn't that nice and just
today the chinese military posted a
ridiculous propaganda video it sounds
like something tom cruise produced of
its troops launching missiles grabbing
weapons and taking off in fighter jets
nice to know they have a military and a
tape recorder the white house seized
this issue as so perilous they sent out
john kirby to the white house briefing
room today to discuss this in detail for
over an hour
he started with why the white house
wasn't more supportive of a potential
visit from the start
why was the speaker being urged not to
go
i don't know that she was urged not to
go who urged her not to go the president
said on august 20th that the military
doesn't think it's a good idea for her
speaker makes her own decisions
yeah it's true that's exactly what the
president said uh the entire appearance
by kirby revealed that the white house
is obviously kind of scared the white
house took on a tone that can be
described at best as deferential towards
the prc and at worst
groveling towards president xi
we have repeatedly said
that we oppose any unilateral changes to
the status quo from either side
we have said that we do not support
taiwan independence
and we have said that we expect
cross-strait differences to be resolved
by peaceful means
why is that necessary to say something
that's been on the books for 50 years
never mind the fact that his boss the
commander-in-chief and just two months
ago that of course we would defend
taiwan's independence remember we would
fight if taiwan was invaded but the
messaging only got worse from there
after kirby departed the briefing room
in comes
karine john pierre who displayed a
stunning lack of interest and knowledge
of most aspects of the chinese threat
three days now since a chinese official
publicly threatened to murder speaker
pelosi where is the president
coming out to respond to at the very
least say don't do that well first we've
talked
kirby was just here talking about how um
i have not seen those reports so i'm
just going to say they were going to
maybe shoot down her plane or that they
would it would be within their rights
well we have talked about that we have
said that there's no need for this type
of saber rattling
yeah i know there was some country that
wanted to shoot and shoot down the
speaker uh right out of the sky oh yeah
maybe it was china thanks for uh
straightening me out peter so let's get
this straight the white house press
secretary was unaware of a chinese
threat
the threat on the speaker of the united
states that's not too reassuring i mean
what does she do during the day can she
keep up with the news is that too much
to ask hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else